hi there steve kaufman
um
romanian
fluency in two months
i don't think so
remember i had a program back a while
ago
which i called fluency in five days
where i spent a whole year working on
check
um
first seven
eight months or so basically listening
and reading working at link and then i
started stepping up my online
discussions with czech tutors and then i
eventually went to prague and i spent
five days there four days speaking seven
eight hours a day and at the end of
which i felt i had made major progress i
guess i really can't say i'm fluent in
check
but uh certainly i understand the radio
i've learned a lot about czech history
and when i was in prague i was
carrying on conversations and and having
a great time
so that the whole idea was and i picked
up on something that dr houliganov
a wonderful multilingual person who
imitates russian accents and stuff
and who's popular here on youtube and he
had said that your passive vocabulary
will be activated within three days so i
gave myself an extra two days but still
i can't say that i achieved fluency not
in five days and not really even within
that whole
period but i can read checkbooks i can
understand czech radio and i can get
along and check so i'm happy and i will
continue to work on my check but
romanian now
i guess i started around the 10th 15th
i'm not sure when
of
may
may no april
let me think no yeah of april and um
so i've had about six weeks and it'll be
close to two or eight weeks by the time
i leave romania
so uh six weeks of prep
six or seven weeks of prep
and of course it's getting closer
because um
next week next monday i arrive in vienna
uh there's a
and i'm going to vienna because
a little bit of the background uh we
deal with a company that's based in
vienna called schweikhofer which is a a
lumber company a very successful company
headed up by a very dynamic um
individual one of the most effective
um executives and business people in the
lumber business softwood lumber business
as far as i'm concerned and he has built
sawmills in romania and we are buying
lumber from
uh these sawmills for shipment into the
u.s east coast
and mr schweikover every year has a
special prize for design with wood and
i've been invited every year to go and
take part in these ceremonies and i've
never done so like i've known mr
schweikover for quite a few years and so
i decided this year since we're dealing
with him and the mills in romania that i
would go to vienna and if i go to vienna
then i have to visit the sawmills in
romania and if i'm going to visit the
sawmills in romania then i was
determined that i would learn some
romanian and it coincided with about the
time that we introduced romanian at link
so for the last six weeks or so as many
of you know um i've been working on my
romanian
before so and of course the test will be
when i arrive in romania on the evening
of the 5th
of june and i'll have the 6th 7th 8th
and 9th
departing on the 10th returning here on
the 10th
so how much will i be able to do in
romanian we will see
i promised to do a video in romania
talking with some romanians but before
getting into that
um i want to talk a bit about how
exciting it is to learn languages on the
internet all right that's a theme that i
get back to all the time but
we introduced romanian at link
we had no content
a couple of our members gave us a small
amount of content there was no content
so i had to go out and create some
uh so i was able to contact through
elance which is a very useful site on
the internet e
capital l a n c e where you can contact
freelance people for outsourcing and so
i have now
a total of three tutors via elaz
for romanian uh i was able to find
people as i explained before
to translate these 150 basic sentences
to translate them and record them and i
put i loaded this up as content into
link so another 30 40 people have been
able to use this
in link and it's all available free of
charge i don't mind i do it for myself
and yet other people are able to benefit
um
then i had uh people do pod at least
transcripts of the radio romania podcast
and i've tried a number of different
transcribers and i've got one now that's
extremely good and quite reasonable
uh she volunteered
that there was
like a number of resources a grammar
book and she volunteered this one site
called vorbeem or vor beach romaneste
and it's put out by the instituto
intercultural
timoshwara timishwara and there there's
like 22 lessons audio and text
so i initially imported those for my own
use into link
and then i approached my this person who
had told me about it and i asked her i
said could you approach
the instituto
intercultural timeshwara ask them if we
could share this amongst other learners
at link it's available for free download
and they came back immediately said yes
which is wonderful because all the time
that i've approached you know echo must
be for russian or uh jessica rose class
for check for permission to share their
material at our website they don't even
answer
they don't even answer so here we got an
answer right away so i loaded up 22
lessons today of romanian audio and text
using the link system so
however many people want to access that
through link are welcome to use it
uh so i mean it's just amazing how all
this stuff works also
on that romanest uh
war beach vorbit romaneste
website
uh there is a pdf grammar book a very
good one with lots of examples
so
i uh
emailed the pdf grammar book
to my um
kindle account
uh on my ipad
so now when i travel
and also on my iphone so now of course
when i travel i'll have my iphone
and i'll have my ipad
and i have all of my recent lessons
on here
on my ipad uh that i've downloaded onto
the ipad because i mean anything that i
have
on link on the computer is now available
to me on the ipad now granted right now
i have to create the links on the
computer because it's much more
convenient but i just create them very
very quickly and then i do the reading
and reviewing and listening on my
ipad and i just spent the last 20
minutes organizing all these lessons
that i have
radio romania podcast with transcripts
um
you know the lessons from
this uh vorbit romaneste
and
so i'll have those available to review
on the plane
as well as
the uh
uh
i can't remember the name of it all this
novel that
uh another one of my tutors sent me this
novel it's quite difficult for me but
i've got the audio book and i've got the
text so i can read the um
read the text in pdf format struggle i
can also listen to the audio book
because i've got that sitting on my on
my iphone and also on my
uh nano
now you can say that that's a lot of
investment
in
nano iphone ipad
uh plus the money that i paid for
transcribing
and other services and stuff
but compared to going to a class it's
peanuts uh because if you go to a class
five days a week three hours a day
whatever you're looking at a thousand
dollars every month
and and yet those are things that those
are expenses that are just gone whereas
here a lot of what i'm doing i'm able to
share with other people
uh via link people can just download it
i'm able to take it with me review it
wherever i am on the go in the plane
while waiting for a plane at the airport
so
uh
yeah it's just to say that it's and of
course i i won't be fluent in romanian
in this short period of time but i have
learned so much about romania about
romanian history about you know history
about 2 000 years ago 500 years ago uh
different groups hungarians germans
in transylvania
how uh you know the struggle for best
arabia
moldova
uh you know
between the wars the fascists and the
king and stuff like that so when
uh i'm in romania
all the stuff that i've been learning
about in romanian is just going to make
my stay there so much more pleasant plus
i'll be able to communicate at some
level how well i'll be able to
communicate we will have to see and i
promise a video from romania and that
will be starting on the 6th or 7th of
june that's when i'll be starting on my
little holiday after visiting the
sawmills i'll be driving through
transylvania
one night in brashov two nights in cebu
and while i'm in cebu there is an
international theater festival there and
apparently there's theater in the
streets and in the public squares and so
forth and so on so i'll be able to
wander around
and
try out my romanian so
uh just to update you on my brief
romanian escapade which once it's over i
have to beetle back to my korean because
i don't want to
you know backslide too badly in my
korean so thanks for listening bye for
now